Syrena dive into human factors they're
kind of two halves to it so about
halfway through we'll take a break but
let's just do the first half of it now
because I don't want to run over into
marks upcoming talk at 4:00 so human
factors is something that's kind of near
near and dear to me I actually really
like this subject when I was an
undergrad I took the course 16400 I
really strongly recommend it we can only
cover a very small amount today and I
have less than an hour to get through
all of this for you and but I think it's
really an interesting class and it's
very pertinent to everything related to
to aircraft and aerodynamics and this
class 16400 was one of my favorite
classes still today I refer back to it
and one of the things we did was also go
through different NTSB reports so I gave
it I gave a link there as well and you
can read through accident investigations
and not all of them are scary you know
many of these reports are nobody
actually got injured but it's good to
just read through you know what happened
what was the decision-making what led to
the to the issue it's really a really
interesting exercise and one thing in
particular that we did in that course
16400 was really interesting is that
they they have you be on basically a
flight simulator so you're pretending to
be a pilot and then there's all kinds of
inputs coming into you which is really
what you're going to experience in the
cockpit when you're flying and you got
people talking to you on the radio you
have your passengers inside the plane
you have all kinds of inputs coming up
on the screen you're looking for other
aircraft you're trying to identify an
airport that you're coming up on there's
a lot happening a lot of information and
then we had to basically talk about you
know if a light went out the absence of
a light trying to expect a pilot to
identify that as it's totally
unreasonable so it was really
interesting in taking this course as an
aerospace engineering student at MIT the
lesson was you need to design these
things to be to be better because if you
if you engineered the system such that
somebody under that much stress and
looking at those many inputs were
supposed to notice a light going out
that's totally unreasonable now on the
other hand
about a pilot we will talk a little bit
about how how many inputs are on a on a
person with a pilot how a lot of things
are attributed to pilot error the whole
purpose of this course and the whole
purpose of learning to fly is how you
can minimize the pilot error aspect of
the engineering design aspect but
certainly it's good to experience both
sides designing the aircraft in the
avionics as well as flying the aircraft
so one thing I really want to point out
it's a little bit morbid but I just
wanted to talk about accidents and what
causes them well a very large number of
accidents are what's called controlled
flight into terrain does anyone know
what controlled flight into terrain
means
thank you
yeah so what he said was that there's
there's no instrument error in it's
pilot error so it's not necessarily that
it means that it's pilot error but what
it's saying is that there's nothing
there's nothing physically wrong with
the aircraft so it's not that the engine
broke it's not like the case with
captain Sully where birds were ingested
into the engines the engine stopped
working but it is the case that a fully
functional aircraft was flown into
terrain into a mountain learned to the
ground so why does that happen so as we
just heard it's the pilots fault is one
of the most common most common answers
they attribute things to pilot error and
the NTSB does this a lot if you watch
the movie about captain Sully it made it
seem like the NTSB was out to get him as
well I've heard the reality is that they
were much more friendly towards him but
but the situation is that that's kind of
a natural thing that they have to
explore they ultimately found that he
wasn't at fault but that becomes a big
big issue so I don't think that it's
always the case again that it's pilot
error
please take 16400 and look into that but
for the purposes of this class for this
for being a pilot you need to be aware
of all the things that are under your
control how do you get a really good
weather briefing how do you make sure
you're prepared so that it is not your
fault and you don't have any accidents
so just to get you in the zone for the
types of things we're going to discuss
today here's a practice question I just
want to see where people are on this I
know I haven't taught it yet but I just
want to know what you think the answer
is so I know how much time to spend on
these topics in the next couple slides
I'll give you a chance to read it
okay so how many people think it's a
right how many people think it's be who
had movement on be but nobody fully
raises to the arm on thee all right see
a lot of hands raised uncie
all right how about Dee now that
everybody raised their hands on see
almost no one wants to admit Dee alright
so it is in fact spatial disorientation
so we're gonna talk about the first half
era medical factors and then we'll take
a break and then we'll get into the
aeronautical decision-making
alright so era medical factors so
Phillip has already talked about some of
the regulations associated with getting
your your medical certificate and having
an an AME or an aviation medical
examiner basically check you out so
there are a lot of physiological factors
that can affect a pilot and some of
those you know are unrelated to that
medical exam that can happen to any of
us so we're gonna go through the ones
that are listed here so hypoxia it
basically is related to to not having
enough oxygen or having a reduced amount
of oxygen and there are a lot of
different types of hypoxia and it
resulted a lot of disorientation a lot
of things that you would be able to do
normally you won't be able to do in
those types of conditions so impaired
judgment visual impairment drowsiness
you know a lot of issues can happen if
if you're under that situation so let's
see if we got this video going
he's taken off his mask so he doesn't
have the oxygen
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
if you heard what he just said he's
feeling tinkling and his toes tingling
in his toes
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
what do you feel
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
I'll let you watch the the whole thing
it basically just gets it gets a lot
worse but you can see and one of the
biggest problems is also maybe not being
able to realize that there's a problem
so that's what makes it even more of an
issue another another issue is carbon
monoxide poisoning so this can this can
actually happen in the aircraft that you
that you fly just based on where the
heat comes in and you get you know
headache drowsiness a lot of issues
they're blurred vision the way to detect
that is there's actually a co2 sorry CO
detector carbon monoxide detector inside
the aircraft and so when that that
middle part becomes very dark then
you'll know that there's an issue and so
just it's good to know what the symptoms
are so if you're starting to experience
those symptoms you know what the problem
is and you can for example open your
window to get some fresh air into the
aircraft some aircraft even certain
services have supplemental oxygen so you
can use that as an option as well
there's a another video just for time
I'm not going to go through it but
there's a lot of issues associated with
high g-force and you might have seen
some things with the Top Gun which we
heard from lads is a terrible
representation but even on that one when
they're pulling haiji maneuvers you can
you know we've seen loss of
consciousness and other issues another
another one that you might have actually
heard of this before is hyperventilation
some people hear on on the ground
experience this and so you might just be
over anxious breathing too quickly it
makes you not be able to breathe
properly you might need to just sort of
take a break breathe into a bag another
good reason to have a copilot with you
so a lot of the issues in turn
the disorientation that you face are
somehow related to how your inner ear
works so the the fluid in your inner ear
is sort of related to how how you feel
motion so I won't I won't get into the
details you don't actually have to know
a ton of detail about it but one thing
to know in terms of how you how you feel
motion is that you have fluid moving in
your ear canal you can't actually really
detect the fluid what happens is you
have these little hairs that come up and
so when the fluid changes direction the
so let's say the the fluid starts moving
in a particular direction then all these
hair pieces start moving and so you feel
that motion now that now the fluid can
continue to move in that direction but
over time the the hair follicles will
basically resume where they are they
won't feel motion motion occurring or
they'll basically be stagnant so it
could be the case that the fluid is
moving and the hair is sitting like this
now all of a sudden when the fluid stops
moving the the fluid stops moving the
hair tries to just return to its
previous state and when that happens you
might actually think that you've started
moving in the other direction so this is
an issue where basically if you are
flying along and you start turning and
you're in a constant rate turn you might
start feeling like you're not turning
and then when you come out of that turn
so you roll out and now you're straight
and level again you feel like you have
just started turning to the right so
even though now you're flying straight
and level your your ear is telling you
that you've turned to the right and so
you try to correct
by turning back to the left so it might
be the case that your your airplanes
actual motion was concentrate turn to
the left and then it flattened out but
you don't realize you're flat so you
start turning again so these are reasons
why you don't want to rely on your inner
ear people refer to it is flying by the
seat of your pants
basically what you feel as opposed to
looking at the instruments but actually
the seat of your pants is primarily your
inner ear is what's giving you all these
indications so there's a lot of things
that can contribute to disorientation so
we already talked a little bit about
spatial disorientation well there are a
lot of things so we talked about the
vast ill vestibular system which is that
inner ear but also even visual cues can
provide spacial can cause you to have
spatial disorientation and then the
feeling on your skin so you know how
much you're pressing against the seat
for example so one thing about spatial
disorientation is that when you're when
you're flying and you're looking out the
window you know your eyes are a big part
of your orientation so you're looking at
the horizon and if the horizons tilted
you think you're turning you know that's
that's how you determine what's going on
but there are a lot of false cues you
can get from looking outside so one
thing is that and we spend a little bit
of time talking about IFR flight earlier
today where you can't see outside the
airplane and you're just relying on your
instruments well it's also good to to do
a reference check of your instruments
doing because of some of the tricks your
eyes can play on you so for example if
there is a low cloud layer that's kind
of tilted the horizon might look tilted
it may not look flat and you might think
you're tilted when you're flat you might
think you're flat when you're tilted
there's also other you know because of
the motion in your inner ear when you
actually have a motion in one direction
if you actually turn over if you bend
your head down so let's say you're
writing with a pencil while you were
flying and you dropped your pencil well
when you bend down you actually feel
emotions that don't actually exist you
might think you're sort of
bullying and so that's really not good
so one thing actually if you fly out of
Hanscom you have to wear a badge anyway
and so you have a lanyard maybe like
clip your pencil to that lanyard or do
whatever you can such that you can reach
everything you need to reach without
physically bending over or if you have a
co-pilot that is also a could be a pilot
in command or a safety pilot you can ask
them to take control take and we talked
about positive exchange of controls ask
them to take control of the aircraft
before you reach down to pick up
something because it can have a more
significant effect than you think it
will and I'm I will reserve some of the
aerobatic talk for for mark to discuss
some of these with you in more in more
detail Tina was talking trash about the
auto pilot that that's also a good
argument for yeah you if you have to
bend down and get something you know
take your hands off the controls
completely that's better than leaving
them on while you're fishing around for
something and if you have an auto pilot
yet better
I think the auto pilot is a very
important tool to use when you're flying
I was just cautioning against it again
when I was flying on my checkride with
mark up there mysteriously the autopilot
stopped working and I had to perform
everything without it so you can't rely
on that when you're flying it could stop
working but also your check ride pilot
will not let you use one so this is
something once you're flying and you can
even ask your instructor to help you
with that to actually get a sense of
these disorientation
you can try you know climbing while
accelerating climbing while turning
these different types of motions and
also consider moving your head making
sure the other person has the flight
controls to experience some of these
motions or if you'd like over near I
think building 33 are building 35 they
have a centrifuge and you can experience
a lot of these things as well so how do
you how do you deal with all these
disorientation 'he's that are happening
one is just being aware of the causes of
them help making sure you know that
they're they're getting kind of
briefings in advance so you know what's
happening
and and really try to avoid sudden head
movements when you're flying so we've
talked about scanning and looking for
traffic but avoid very sudden head
movements while you're flying because
you are moving and it can cause you to
have a lot of effects and then the other
thing is just being well-rested eating
properly if you're you know if you're
hungry if you're tired your body is not
at its best it can also contribute so
here are just some more examples of the
visual illusions so and then they're
also times when the visual illusions are
worse
so nighttime we're gonna have a whole
section on night flying tomorrow but as
it relates to human factors I will say
that you might think you're coming in
towards the airport but you're actually
seeing a cluster of lights that's a city
somewhere else you might start going to
the wrong place if you don't keep
referencing your instruments you might
not notice that you're kind of off track
I'll give you one tip though I was
flying to Hyannis Hyannis is a is a city
right at the base of the Cape before you
go all the way down the arm of the Cape
and there's a great restaurant there
right next to the Hyannis Airport a
little French restaurant during the day
they have kind of little sandwiches and
pastries and at night it becomes kind of
a nicer French restaurant so I was
actually flying there at night and
coming in to Hyannis as having a little
bit of issue because my heading
indicator kept processing and I wasn't
sure exactly and things happened very
quickly because I'd been talking about
the the Bravo clearances going from
Bedford over there you're you're talking
all these controllers and worrying about
your altitude and so there's a lot
happening and as I got close to the
Hyannis Airport I wasn't exactly sure
that I was going for that they have two
different intersecting runways I wasn't
exactly sure I was lined up for the
correct runway so I just talked to the
tower controller and I told them that I
was having this issue and so they lit up
the runway that I was trying to land
that very bright just for a moment so I
could get you know oriented and get
myself situated and it was very great so
so good also to use other people whether
it's a flight service folks or the tower
folks to give you help when you need it
so this is also just another thing that
happens at night and we'll talk about
this with the night flying that
sometimes a stationary light can appear
to move and so you have to be careful
don't trust everything you see a big one
in terms of an optical illusion whether
it's day or night is they that if a
runway is not flat but it's actually
inclined going up or incline going down
not only as it relates to performance
when we're talking about how long it
takes you to to land but also as you're
coming in you might think that you're a
different place than you are this is
also the case you know if the runways is
wider or narrower than you're used to so
at Hanscom you might have very wide
runways if you fly out of Beverly you
have narrower runway so just that
difference can make you think you're at
a different orientation or you're higher
or lower than where you are you can you
go back to that one so basically they're
saying if the runway is sloped and you
rely on your ordinary sight picture you
might follow a higher or lower than
standard glide path yeah absolutely so
what it's saying the so that the top one
is showing that you know obviously
that's just when it's flat and so when
it's inclined up you might you might try
to be farther away so that you get the
same picture so that the dotted aircraft
is where you should be but the solid
aircraft is where you might actually be
where you're trying to compensate
because of the illusion and then if
there's a featureless terrain it can
really affect you as well so like right
now we have a snowy condition so it's
harder to see what's what's happening it
makes it difficult and in general it
makes you fly a lower approach which is
not good okay and then just a couple
more
I won't dive into each of them but you
know fog or haze different types of
things can cause a mirage or can cause
an illusion and so you really want to
keep referencing your instruments to
make sure you are in fact holding the
altitude or use your autopilot to help
you out
and of course any reference system so if
you have a vazhi or a poppy those are
great tools that even if it looks like
the the runway is one place to the other
if it's if the lights are all red you're
too low okay another one is motion
sickness so one thing I want to tell you
about motion sickness is when you go up
and you take your first discovery flight
come out of this class you're ready to
go you might feel a little bit motion
sick and that's okay you're in a tiny
airplane it might be bouncing around a
little bit what I'm here to say is that
that goes away you can actually train
your body to get used to it and and kind
of get over that motion sickness but
unfortunately if you you can lose that
tolerance that you built up if you you
know wait a really long time between
flights I'm at MIT so I don't know how
much I need to tell you about stress I
think we all know about stress we have
different ways of dealing with it
but just as much as it affects your
ability to take an exam at MIT that
stress can also affect your ability to
fly and think think logically as you
might need to to make to do aeronautical
decision-making and that's a good time
to think about whether you should bring
an instructor along on a trip you know
if you're tired or you're upset or about
something then be part of a two-pilot
crew exactly fatigue is a big one if you
do take my advice and look at those NTSB
reports a large number of them are
talking about you know airline pilots
that have just you know been flying for
22 hours and something happens where
whereas if you really think through it
you know maybe maybe that issue wouldn't
have happened but they're so tired that
those things resulted in issues so
really be mindful of how much fatigue
can affect your ability to fly and what
stresses it puts on the pilot
dehydration and heat stroke or big ones
here in this area gets very hot in the
summers make sure to bring a bottle of
water with you when you go flying it can
be a big issue and
you know if you're feeling kind of
lightheaded take it take a drink of
water and it can make a big big
difference all right so no alcohol or
drugs while flying or before flying
there are some specific regulations
they're much more strict than driving
which i think is a good thing so please
take a look at that 14 CFR part 91 the
blood-alcohol level and the time since
the last drink it's really not worth it
you're flying as a hobby for fun don't
do something that's unsafe some of these
are ways to remember the bottle to
throttle examples here so I'll let you
take a look at those also don't carry
drugs I don't know if I need to
elaborate on that okay so we talked
about vision vision is one of the things
that in your medical exam your AME is
going to look at your vision and test
your ability to see one thing to keep in
mind is that when you're looking at out
your windshield you can basically kind
of zone out and so you think you're
looking at your went out your windshield
and you're scanning for aircraft but
you've sort of stopped paying attention
so one thing that they recommend you do
is actually have a series of very
specific eye movements I just moved my
head but again don't move your head but
kind of look with your eyes to scan
across so that you're actually
specifically deciding and you're
specifically looking and scanning the
air for other aircraft and tell this to
your passengers you don't have to be a
trained pilot to look for aircraft
I always tell all of my passengers look
out the window tell me if you see other
aircraft okay so we're gonna dive into
aeronautical decision-making one quick
thing I'll say is that I brought a
couple of magazines here although some
of them are older they have some good
content so this one is about aviation
safety for folks today that we're
interested in the talk about instrument
flight there's actually a magazine
called IFR refresher and specifically
focuses on topics related to instrument
flight
then another a number of these aviation
safety that talk about topics that I
felt were relevant such as flying with
icing is one of the ones here and flying
at night and then there's a general IFR
magazine that just talks about some good
articles about how you handle your
skills and flying instrument approaches
such as an ILS so these are just kind of
first-come first-serve over here so
aeronautical decision making so how you
make decisions when you're in the
cockpit can really affect how you
successfully exit a very negative
situation so whether it's what we were
just talking about with regard to having
spatial disorientation or having carbon
monoxide poisoning versus an engine
failure or specific issue or a weather
issue the way that you go about making a
decision can significantly impact the
outcome so we're gonna talk about
decision making hazards how we go about
evaluating risks and having personal
checklists so in aeronautical
decision-making one thing to think about
is just that there is a way that you can
teach someone how to make good decisions
so in addition to learning about your
airplane and learning how to fly one
thing that throughout your pilot
training is that you'll learn how to
make decisions so crew resource
management is one specific aspect and
we've been alluding to that all day
talking about how to use either your
copilot or whoever it is that's sitting
next to you in the plane or your other
passengers as well there are a number of
aircraft that we talked about and we
discussed the FAA regulations earlier
about mandated requirements to have a
co-pilot or sometimes other folks but
there are even people outside your
cockpit that you could rely on air
traffic controllers we talked about
flight service stations for example
so again really think about when you're
flying
although the FAA might require just a
crew of one whether you really are all
alone or there other people you can rely
on so there are a lot of aspects to
making good decisions and this is part
of why pilots love talking to other
pilots they also just like discussing
you know if they encountered an issue
how they went about dealing with that
issue and talking to other people about
their experiences is actually a good way
to learn one thing you should also know
is about your personal attitudes I think
that might have been another reason
laz our f-22 pilot yesterday was so
against Top Gun the concept of being a
very arrogant person that violates the
rules is really not a good stereotype
for a pilot because people that fly like
that are more likely to have accidents
how you can modify your behavior how to
recognize and cope with stress we could
certainly use that here at MIT and then
how to really assess risks properly so
we talked about weather as an example
how do you know if you have the right
weather information have you evaluated a
risk appropriately and we've really
tried to give you pointers and cues for
that and especially if they tell you VFR
flight not advisable it's not advisable
that means that it's probably a bad idea
so hazards and risks so a hazard is
basically a condition or an event
something that you might encounter where
where as risk is basically your
assessment you know of how how likely is
that risk
you know how likely is that hazard going
to come to be what impact could that
hazard have on your outcome
so one thing again is about your
attitude so so don't be like those Top
Gun pilots if you're a very anti
Authority and you say you know I don't
care even if the the weather folks said
VFR flight not advisable I'm a great
pilot I can do it anyway that type of
attitude is probably going to lead you
in unsafe condition it's really not
not a good idea we also discussed the
concept of personal minimums and setting
personal minimums for yourself the
reason is that you know today for
example or after you've done a little
bit of flying you might have a good
sense of what you're comfortable with
you might have gone up with a lot of
gusting winds and so you might decide
that hey I was a little bit
uncomfortable with winds gusting to 20
knots I even if my aircraft is capable
of it
I think that's something that until I
get a little bit more experienced I'm in
a set as a personal minimum
I don't want winds gusting over 15 knots
before I decide to take a flight by
myself so you can set your personal
minimums why are we talking about that
well the reason is on the actual day
that you're flying you may reevaluate
the situation you might really want to
go flying that day maybe you've already
arranged with a friend to come with you
maybe have a destination you're really
trying to reach Phillip described a
number of situations where he's flying
cross-country he has a plan he has to
follow it and he can't really be away
you know missing several days where he
was trying to go and so sometimes in the
moment you might have an impulsive
nature you might decide that I I think I
can do it I'm sure it's fine so having
personal minimums and actually writing
those down are a really good way to hold
yourself accountable to what you had
decided in a calm state of mind was a
good restriction so one thing to keep in
mind is the assessment of risk you also
shouldn't be overly risk-averse you know
they the FAA has guidance on what type
of equipment is required in your
aircraft so certain things are that's
required if it's not there you can't fly
but there are other things that are
optional and so if there's a piece of
equipment that's optional that's not
functional there's an important there's
a lot of importance around understanding
what is the risk of that not being
operational as an example and we'll go
through a checklist
in a little bit to assess both your
personal state of being or aircraft
state of being the environment and
assessing all those risks and together
but for a given risk you want to know
one how likely is it so maybe if you're
talking about whether there's a chance
that a storm will come in there's a
chance that it won't then also the
severity you know are we talking about
some light rain showers are we talking
about you know very very dangerous front
with icing or thunderstorms so that's
the difference between the likelihood
and the severity both of those have to
be assessed for a given risk given
hazard that you encounter when you
assess its risk so there's this way of
checking yourself it's called I'm safe
so this is just determining just just
you not the airplane not the environment
as a pilot if you're safe to fly so do
you have an illness are you taking
medications that might affect your
ability to fly are you very stressed out
you know do you have your thermodynamics
final coming up and you're really
nervous about it are you do you have you
know again we talked about there also
legal regulations you can't have alcohol
or drugs that could affect your ability
to fly are you just very tired or really
just are you very distracted by
something that's happening a the pavé
checklist is the one I was referring to
that actually considers all of these
different things so so the I'm safe is
just the pilot AE is referring to the
aircraft so this is when we were talking
about our certain things different about
the aircraft maybe it's a new aircraft
that you're not really comfortable with
maybe you're checked out but you don't
have that many hours in that particular
aircraft or maybe you know we've talked
about the difference between steam gauge
in G 1000 maybe you're really used to
flying steam gauge and this is a G 1000
so there's nothing actually wrong with
the airplane but you may be less
comfortable environmental so that could
be weather that could be flying to a new
airport that could be flying to an
airport that has some special conditions
maybe it's a grass strip you're lying to
cat Aimie
which is a grass runway
out at Martha's Vineyard right next to
the beach it's really beautiful I
recommend it but maybe it fits your
first time flying to a soft field that
could be a concern external pressures
that's what we were just talking about
you're already committed to being
somewhere later in the day you're you've
met up with somebody you're with a
friend you had decided to take them
flying they really want to go but the
weather is looking a little bit iffy so
one thing that's good about this pave
checklist is to kind of put things in
perspective that maybe you know maybe
you're you're feeling a little bit
stressed out or distracted about it mit
exam but the aircraft is the one that
you've been flying a lot you're very
familiar with it you have a lot of time
on the aircraft everything is working
well you have a good amount of fuel the
weather is great it's a beautiful day
you're flying too familiar airports and
you don't have any external pressures
that day there's no one you're trying to
meet there's nothing you're trying to
get done so that might be a good day
that okay one of these things is a
little bit iffy nothing crossed your
your minimums but it's it's just
something that maybe you could still go
ahead and fly however if it's multiple
things if it's you know a different
aircraft it's a different location
you're having stresses these start
becoming times that you want to take
these risks even more seriously because
as they come together it could affect
your ability to have a safe flight so
just these types of personal checklists
are a great way to assess risk and and
make decisions as you're trying to
decide whether or not to go on a flight
and these are just a breakdown of some
of the things I just said on the
environmental condition so nighttime is
also on there tomorrow we'll talk about
night flying in particular and and the
fact that basically in the US with your
gesture private pilot's license you can
fly at night a lot of other countries
consider night flying just as as
advanced as instrument flying and you
need your instrument rating to fly at
night because of all the concerns about
not being able to see much outside your
airplane so be be mindful that you know
it's a slightly more challenging
condition to fly in and how does that
affect your ability to assess the other
risks that might be taking place
I really would recommend especially when
you're first getting certified you don't
really make plans anywhere near the time
that you're supposed to be done flying
we try you know most flight schools will
give you a flight block of two and a
half hours make sure that you don't have
to be anywhere even for a few hours
after that in case the weather got bad
you had to land somewhere else you don't
want those external pressures affecting
your decision-making when you're in the
cockpit this is another way to think
about it in terms of this 5p checklist
so they're there certain kind of
different parts through the flight we
discuss you know the pre-flight takeoff
while you're you know kind of cruising
along or descending and you're flying
and it might be good to kind of look
through all of these these different
aspects about when you're flying and
kind of checklist for yourself to
understand what's happening there are a
lot of different resources that talk
about aeronautical decision making I
think one of the best resources is
really talking to other pilots about
experiences that they've they've gone
through and learning after you go
through an experience reflecting
afterwards whether it's through your
instructor with your friends you know
what happened what could I have done
differently you know was that the right
decision to make so even these little
things like Phillip was talking about
flying with with Roxanna trying to avoid
some weather there was rain you know
thinking about how he evaluated that
risk of that thunderstorm what could he
have done differently was that the right
decision and in general making a
conservative decision is good because
it's your life at stake that we're
talking about all right so I think we've
talked a lot about this is there are
there any specific questions on
aeronautical decision-making or human
factors in general yes
from the coop these refined
we're gonna cover that in the at the
very end there's a Cirrus at least put
together this big matrix they don't tell
you how often to fly to practice but
they tell you given how recently you've
been flying and practicing here's the
kind of weather that you should be
challenging to the the question for
those who couldn't here was just about
the currency so how is are there rules
about how how often you need to fly and
there are rules especially related to
carrying passengers at night for example
there are certain legal currency
requirements but just as Phillip said
there's also just personal minimums that
you might want to set for yourself if
you haven't gone flying for a month you
may be legally current but may not be a
good time to take a bunch of passengers
to a new destination that you haven't
flown to before yeah so you remember
from yesterday there's that 90 day it's
three takeoffs and landings within the
preceding 90 days before you can carry
passengers that's a good minimum a lot
depends on the type of aircraft and how
familiar you are with it so if you have
500 hours in a very logically designed
airplane like the Cirrus you know then
you're gonna be safe probably without
flying too often in a more complicated
aircraft you know that has buttons and
levers just randomly strewn across the
panel which seems to be the industry
standard you know if you haven't flown
it for a month you may actually be a
little bit at sea as to well you know
where we are the flaps where's the gear
so a lot depends on how many hours of
experience you have in the type of
aircraft you're gonna fly and just how
inherently challenging it is to fly you
know the currency requirements practical
currency requirements for a multi-engine
piston airplane are gonna be very
different from those that you might use
in a Piper Cub yeah when we you know
when we hold the class earlier I think
there were you know 70 of you have
really only flown once or not at all and
so that's a lot of a lot of people that
don't have flying experience so I would
say you know back before I had 200 hours
or even before I had a hundred hours of
flying experience I'm I actually set
very strict currency requirements I had
to fly you know two times a week
before I really felt comfortable taking
up a passenger oh and I wanted to fly
relatively frequently with an instructor
and practice stall recovery these types
of things and I think that's good make
it make it as much as you need to in
order to be safe yeah you could also
decide again if you haven't flown for a
while are you going to fly an IFR
approach down to minimums you know down
to 200 feet above the runway in the
clouds by yourself in an airplane with
no autopilot which would be League would
be legal or are you gonna say look I'm a
little bit rusty so I'm gonna only fly
on a fairly calm wind
VFR day and get get back into it so a
lot depends on the challenge of the
flight that you're considering it also
has a question I'll tell you one more
little story a friend of mine had a
twin-engine airplane a Cessna 340 which
is a very complicated airplane with he
has six fuel tanks and all kinds of
levers it's pressurized off the
turbochargers anyway one engine caught
on fire so an engine caught on fire he's
got four or five people from his family
in the back and he manages to get the
fire out by cutting off the fuel I guess
in the burning engine he's right about
Bradley field in Connecticut so that's
one of the largest airports actually in
the world it's probably among the top
few percent of big airports in the world
in terms of physical size they have
regular airline service they have a
full-time fire department they have a
control tower they have a runway that's
about as long as Logan's you know
something like two miles close to two
miles long runway so he decides well
I've got one engine it's night time it's
night the controllers are right here
should I just you know spiral down and
land on one of these huge runways at
Bradley and but the fire department come
up and meet the airplane or that's
option one let's see what you guys think
option two let me continue to my home
airport of Fitchburg which is unattended
I don't think there's a fire department
that's there
there's no control tower the runway is
pretty short 4,500 feet but on the other
hand it is the home airport so it's very
familiar and he's got one engine left so
it's an airplane you only need one
engine to descend so what do you guys
think a or B minded Bradley or I go to
Pittsburgh okay what do you think this
guy did he went to Pittsburgh and he
wrecked the airplane you know he landed
but I don't know it's twins
with one engine and they always say the
second engine carries you to the scene
of the accident we'll talk about that
tomorrow
so they just are hard it's hard to
maintain it's hard to keep him going
perfectly straight so of course he
didn't go perfectly straight time and
runway went off the side of the art
runway did some damage to the airplane
nobody was hurt fortunately the
punchline of the story is he doesn't
tell this as an example of bad
aeronautical decision-making he tells
this as a story of good decisions and
making good decisions to pilot and I'm
not really sure why anyway I just wanted
to tell you I can despite all those
checklists people can have very
different perspectives on what
constitutes a wise decision but
personally I try to do you know I have
an ATP but I try to do flights whenever
possible that require only a student
pilot level of skill and that gives me a
nice margin
you